사남이 간다 오늘은 대한민국 최대
상권인 강남역에 와 있습니다 강남역
같은 경우에는 평일에 출근길로 사람이
많고 주말에는 데이트 코스로 유동
인구가 굉장히 많은 곳인데 근데
이곳에 최근에 공실이 좀 많다라고
합니다 그래서 오늘 현장에 가서
공실률이 얼마나 많고 상권이 좀
어떻게 변했는지 한번 직접 가서
보도록 하겠습니다 그리고 강남역 빌딩
투자에 대한 팁도 어 설명드릴
예정이니까이 영상 끝까지 봐주시면
감사하겠습니다
[음악]
네 강남역 상권 같은 경우에는
강남역부터 노년까지 이어지는 상권을
강남역 상권이라고 불립니다 강남역
같은 경우에는 하루 유동 인구가 무려
50만 명이 탁할 정도로 대한민국에서
유동 인구가 가장 많은 곳이라고
보시면 됩니다데 하지만 최근에 상권이
좀 안 좋아지면서 공실률이 많아졌다는
얘기가 좀 많은데 부동산 원에서
발표한 자료에 따르면 약 한 10%
정도가 공실율이 해가지고 제가 지금
현장에서 봤는데 10% 보다 많은 거
같아요 제가 몇 개월 전에도 영상을
좀 찍었었는데 그때보다는 좀 괜찮아진
거 같습니다 그래서 그때는 임대
현수막도 좀 많이 붙여져 있었는데
최근에는 임대가 들어와 있거나 아니면
이제 현수막이 제거가 돼 있습니다
그래서 보통 그 경우에는 이제 임대차
계약이 된 경우가 많거든요 그래서
최근에는 조금 살아나는 분위기인 거
같습니다 그래서 공실률이 높았던 이유
중에 가장 큰게 임대료가 높았습니다네
그래서 임대료를 낮추면 아무래도 빌딩
가격이 영향이 크기 때문에 일부로
마치지 않고 버틴 거예요 그리고
강남역 쪽에 건물주 분들의 특징이
되게 오래 전부터 소유하신 분들이
많습니다 그래서 자산가 분들이 많이
있어요 그래서이 분들은 굳이 임대를
안 맞춰도 버틸 힘이 있습니다 그리고
강남역 같은 경우에는 손 박기도
일어나지 않아요 진짜 1년에 빌딩
거래가 한게 있을까 말까입니다 그래서
제가 좀 조사를 해보니까 최근 거래된
사례가 바로 비랑 김태희 부부의
사례입니다 그래서 그 사례 같은
경우에는 21년도 요 거의 3년 정도
됐습니다네 그래서 그 정도로 빌딩
거래가 굉장히 좀 없는 곳이에요
그래서 그만큼 되게 좀 희소성이 있는
곳이라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다 지금
1층 2층 같은 경우에는 그냥 공실로
비어 놓는 경우가 많은데 최근에
강남역 상권을 좀 분석해 보니까
소매점이나 이런 그 판매점 같은게 좀
줄어들고 병원이 좀 많이 늘어났습니다
그래서 제가 오늘 실제로 가서 또
보니까 상부층에 병원이 입전 있는
경우가 많습니다 그래 그 이유가
뭐냐면 일단 강남역 같은 경우에는
교통이 너무 좋아요 호선 뭐 신분당선
구호선 그 역도 너무 잘돼 있고
그리고 무엇보다 거기 웬만한 경기도
가는 광역 버스가 다 있습니다 교통이
너무 좋아요 그래서 병원을 하기에는
입지적으로 너무 좋습니다네 그래서이
상부층의 임대는 너무 잘되는 거
같아요 지금 아직 강남역데 좀
문제점이 뭐냐면 여기가 약간 좀
지대가 낮습니다 그래서 침수가 좀
많이 이 돼요 그래서 얼마 전에
저희가 이제 그때 비가 많이 왔을
때도 강남역이 거의 다 잠겼습니다 그
정도로 좀 이렇게 침수가 잘되는
곳이긴 합니다 이번 여름에 좀 비가
어느 정도 많이 올지 모르겠지만 이쪽
지역에 만약에 비가 오면 침수가 많이
되는 건 좀 단점이라고 좀 보여지긴
합니다이랑 김태희 부부가 21년도
920억 매입을 했는데 그때 당시에
참 말이 많았어요 이거 뭐 잘못 산
거 아니냐 고점에 산 거 아니냐라고
얘기가 좀 많았는데 최근에 좀 건물을
보면은 1층에 그 < shall
expect 버거가 들어와 있습니다
그래서 원래 건너편에 들어와 있었는데
그게 임대료가 좀 높았어요 한 1억
5천 정도 됐는데 지금 비랑 김태일
건물 같은 경우에는 한 1억 정도에
맞춰진 곳으로 좀 보여집니다 그래서
지금 1층에는 쉐쉐 버고 나머지는
진짜 뭐 병원이 다 임차가 돼 있고
지금 만실입니다 그래서 그때 매입했을
때 보증금 한 40억에 월세 한 2억
2천 정도로 알려져 있는데 아마
그거보다 좀 더 높게 지금 받고 있는
것으로 예상이 됩니다 그래서 뭐예
컨데 거의 한 3억 가까이 받을
것으로 좀 예상이 되는데 그래서
매입과 대비했을 때 강남 치고는
수익률이 좀 되게 높은 편입니다 1층
쉐쉐 버거에 대해서 좀 설명을
드리자면 지금 그쪽 쉐쉐 버거 있는
길이 지금 쉐쉐 버거 들어와 있고 좀
더 가면 파브 가이지 들어와 있고
그다음에 지금 좀 더 가면 슈퍼두퍼
들어와 있습니다 그래서 정말 그 뭔가
햄버거 격전지 불릴 정도로 유명한
햄버거 업체들이 좀 많이 들어와
있는데이 세 군데 업체 중에 앞으로
좀 어디가 사람들이 많을지 좀 되게
그것도 관찰할 포인트인 거 같습니다
강남용 건물투자 팁을 좀 말씀드리면
그 강남대로 기준으로 좌측은 서초도
우측은 역삼동 있니다 근데 이제 용도
지역을 보면은 좌측은 이제 상업지로
돼 있고 우측은 앞쪽만 이제 상업지구
나머진 다 1번 주고지고 되고
있습니다 그래서 상권으로 보자면
좌측이 조금 업종이 되게 다양해요
그래서 예를 들어서 뭐 클럽도 들어가
있고 밤새 놓는듯한 그런 상품이고요
우측은 약간 좀 맛집 위주로 좀 많이
돼 있고 그리고 이제 우측 같은
경우에는 좀 이렇게 언덕길이 많이
있어요 그래서 상권이 조금 확장될
만한 좀 그런 한계 부분도 좀
있습니다네 그래서 여러분들이 만약에
투자하실 때는 좌측 같은 경우에는
상업지 때문에 가격이 너무 비싸요네
너무 비싸고 분양 상가가 많이
있습니다 그래서 실질적으로 투자한다
그러면 우측에 역삼동 상권을 좀 많이
투자를 할 텐데 근데 여기서 이제
언덕길이 많다 보니까 상권의 확장에
조금 제한이 있습니다 그래서 어느
정도의 사람 유동인구가 좀 있을지 좀
유심히 파악하실 필요가 있고 그거에
따라서 공실 율이라지 임대료와 차이가
많이 있기 때문에 어이 부분 참고해서
보시면 좋을 것 같고 그 아무래도
언덕길이 있다 보니까 한 계층을
인정받을 수 있는 그런 장점도 있어요
그래서 실제로 나영씨 건물을 보면은
이제 한 계층을 좀 인정받은 그런
건물입니다 그래서 그런 건물도
있으니까 어 좀 유심히 찾아보시면
좋을 것 같습니다네 그래서 강남역
저는 전망을 어찌됐든 교통도 너무
좋고 분성 너무 좋기 때문에 조금 뭐
임대료를 조금 내리거나 뭔가 강남만의
뭔가 좀 특색을 조금 갖춘다면 저는
충분히 다시 살아날 거라고 생각을
하고 정말 대한민국 최고의 상권의
명성을 다시 유지하지 않을까 어 저는
렇게 좀 생각을 합니다 그리고 저는
아직까지는 대한민국 그리고 강남
내에서이 강남역 상권은 좀 좋다라고
생각하기 때문에 여러분들이 만약에
강남역 투자를 생각하신다면 좌측에
서초동 사기 어렵고 우측에 역삼동
쪽에 어상 좀 잘 확장될 만한 곳에
한 계층 인정받으면 더 좋고 어 그런
건물을 싸게 매입해서 어 상권이
확장될 때 개발을 한다든지 조금
임차인 개선을 한다든지 어 이런
부분은 조금 기억하셨다가 어
투자하시면 어 좋을 것 같습니다네
오늘 강남역 상권에 대해서 좀 설명을
드렸는데 좀 도움이 되셨나요 현재
지금 강남역 빌딩 상황이 좀 어떻게
됐고 앞으로 좀 어떻게 될 건지 좀
여러분들한테 말씀을 드렸는데 이런
상권이 좀 궁금하다 하시는 분들은
댓글 남겨 주시면 그쪽도 가서 한번
좀 상권 분석을 해보도록 하겠습니다이
영상이 마음에 드셨다면 좋아요 구독
눌러 주시고요 다음 시간에 찾아뵙도록
하겠습니다 거물은 역시 의사나
[음악]